vice president kamala harris sits on a
fortune worth about
seven million dollars her portfolio
shared with husband and second gentleman
douglas emhoff
comprises largely of real estate
pensions and retirement accounts
currently the couple owns homes in la
and dc worth an estimated 5 million
dollars before debt
harris has two pensions from her time
working in california's government worth
about 1 million dollars
and emhoff has about 1.2 million dollars
in retirement accounts
here's how it came together after
graduating in 1989
harris started working at the alameda
county district attorney's office
in 1998 she moved to san francisco to
work for the da's office there
buying a condo in the city for three
hundred thousand dollars
this year she sold it for 860 000
in 2003 harris won election to become
san francisco's district attorney
and earned 140 000 the next year
according to tax returns
after being elected california attorney
general in 2010
harris married her husband douglas
emhoff in 2014.
emhoff was an entertainment litigator
for a law firm called venable in los
angeles
and since being married he reported
earning more than one million dollars
every year on their joint tax filings
after harris announced her plans to run
for the senate in 2015
she filed a detailed financial
disclosure form with the government
it showed the couple's joint assets and
liabilities not including personal
residential real estate were worth
somewhere between 1 million dollars and
3.9 million dollars
around the same time emhoff also
offloaded more than two dozen
conflict-prone stock holdings in
companies
such as cvs health and oracle similar to
other politicians
increased popularity has helped harris's
earning power
her memoir the truths we hold came out
in 2019
and sold more than 200 000 copies
since 2018 she has reported earning 879
thousand dollars from writing
according to her tax filings as vice
president
harris now earns 230 700
a year 33 percent more than when she was
a senator
if recent history is any indication
harris should be able to earn even more
once she is out of office
a few months ago mike pence signed a
book deal of his own
rumored to be worth somewhere in the
range of three to four million dollars
and after joe biden served as vice
president he and his wife jill gave
speeches across the country and
published two books
earning 17 million dollars in four years
you